das ist absolut papieren die singenden
braun mäuse sprechen miteinander das ist
das ergebnis einer studie
das forschungsteam hat sich sehr genau
angesehen was passiert wenn diese mäuse
miteinander türken und tatsächlich ist
das einer menschlichen unterhaltung sehr
ähnlich und das bedeutet dass die
wurzeln unserer sprache schon sehr früh
angelegt wurden wie früher
und was das für die forschung bedeutet
werden wir jetzt bald clixoom zahlen
sind wirklich mehr gibt täglich
faszinierendes 1 videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's mit dem
geheimnis der singenden musik haben sie
bekommen heute mit marius angeschrieben
der sich näher mit dem phänomen der
sprache beschäftigt beifahrer geht es
nämlich nicht nur um den austausch von
informationen sondern auch primär um
soziale botschaften magst du mich mag
ich dich finde ich dich gerade in die
komisch oder nicht alle solche dinge
werden auch über sprache transportiert
gespräche können so viele verschiedene
dinge sein dass auch manche menschen
kann man einfach so easy reden und mit
manchen mit manchen da kommt man einfach
nicht so wichtig auf eine wellenlänge
also irgendwas muss ja in unserer
kommunikation sei was aus dem fall alten
instinkten kommt und zentraler
bestandteil unserer heutigen sprache ist
erziehen kann man genau dass er gerade
festgestellt werden laute können sie die
emotionen des anderen erkennen genau
diese oder kommunikation haben forscher
bei sinkendem braun mäusen untersucht
also was genau passiert im gehirn der
mäuse wenn sie miteinander singen und
eines kann ich sagen da passiert eine
ganze menge
es ist fast schon ein richtiger dialog
der eine macht und hat auf die anderem
aus finanzieller ist es wie bei uns
menschen eine frage und eine antwort
eine richtige unterhaltung bisher man
solche phänomene nur bei primaten
entdeckt aber mäuse können das scheinbar
auch für die studie legten die forscher
bei mäusen den bereich des gehirns lahm
der für die mögliche sprache notwendig
ist der motor cortex und die mäuse
hörten sofort auf zu kommunizieren und
die unfassbare erkennt ist daraus ist
dass bei mäusen und beim menschen der
gleiche teil des gehirns für mündliche
sprache zuständig ist und das bedeutet
laut dem neurobiologen steffenhagen der
an dieser forschung beteiligt war eine
sehr sehr interessante annahmen ihr seid
dafür dass leute demnach müsste es einen
gemeinsamen vorfahren von mäusen um
menschen geben der genau diese fähigkeit
schon hatte und das bedeutet dass das
fundament der sprache unserer sprache
fläche und über 100 millionen jahren
gelegt wurde
holy shit hammer und es gibt noch mehr
von marius wer hat die sprache erfunden
auch beim menschen muss sich sprache am
anfang sehr seltsam angehört haben mehr
dazu erfahrt ihr in diesem video von
marius anklicken anschauen und auf jeden
fall den wissenschafts kanal von marius
angeschrien abonnieren vielen dank
marius dass du hier dabei war es bis
dann bleibt dran